can we limit the probability of the
existence of life outside of our solar
system the fact is that Mars had liquid
water on it we believe it had you know
potential to support you know a microbe
you know airdropped onto Mars two
billion years ago could have survived
potentially
um but can we not say something about
the overall Global odds I've never seen
this I've seen the Drake equation I've
seen I mean what we know is that Mars
had has a lower surface gravity so it
couldn't retain its atmosphere and a
couple of billion years ago it lost its
atmosphere now before that it had liquid
water on the surface and whether what
forms of life it had we don't know and
that's part of the mission of the NASA
Rovers that are being sent
frankly I mean personally I believe that
we have a better chance of finding
traces of Penny early life on Mars in
the caves in the so-called lava tubes
which are these caves that are
underground protected from Postmates
phrase and are not really affected by
the extreme temperature variations on
the surface after the atmosphere was
lost and I'm particularly interested in
going into these caves the lava tubes
and searching for any wall paintings
because maybe intelligent life developed
on Mars twice as fast as it did on Earth
you know a factor of two is not a big
factor and of course today they would
not be able to survive there is no
atmosphere all the liquid water
evaporated but if they existed we might
find some wall paintings and uh and and
moreover we might find some skeletons in
these Lava Tubes so that's my personal
interest going with a drone into these
lava tubes and examining them but then
we cannot say at the moment how to
calibrate you know we cannot say whether
there was a Life on Mars and how
advanced it was until we find any traces
of it just one thing to keep in mind
even Suppose there were cities on the
surface of Mars you might say oh we
don't see any high rise well the point
is that any square kilometer of Mars was
bombarded by 20 Hiroshima atomic bomb
explosions associate triggered by uh
asteroid impacts I I calculated that in
a couple of billion years you basically
get 20
Atomic explosions per square kilometer
and any high rise would be demolished as
a result of that so not to speak about
you know any living creatures
um and obviously without an atmosphere
or liquid water they would have a hard
time surviving uh I first want to start
off with some images so I have an image
here I always like to joke about
um you know it's it's uh it's a very
interesting image I'll just pop on the
screen you won't be able to see it but
it's meteor crater Arizona have you ever
been there Avi no I've seen images of
him so if you remember the images
there's a huge uh you know one you know
plus kilometer crater uh and then I
always joke you know it's so cool that
it struck right next to the gift shop
and uh of course you know they built the
gift shop later but but my question for
you is you know when you look at these
objects um you know when you find this
object you should go through the
calculations that led you to conclude or
in the government to agree with this
calculation that this was Interstellar
but then that you found in Papua New
Guinea around the most likely trajectory
Impact Zone you actually found the
Sphero is it a just so story is it just
like this gift shop appearing next to
the meteor crater in Arizona and if so
if not why let me let me explain first
of all from the Creator you only infer
the kinetic energy the energy carried by
the object that impacted the Earth and
that doesn't tell you separately the
mass of the object and the speed that it
came at it tells you the product of the
mass times the speed squared and that's
all that you can learn from the size and
the shape of the mid of the Cradle so
when examining uh impacts on Earth we
can't really tell where these impactors
came from we can't say whether it's
solar system origin or Interstellar
origin outside the solar system what was
special about the meteor from 2014 is
that the US government satellites and
other sensors detected it when it
exploded in the atmosphere and could
measure its speed and they measure the
speed of 45 kilometers per second in
some direction and we went back in time
and realized that it was not bound to
the sun it was moving faster than the
Escape speed from the Sun and moreover
it was moving very fast even outside the
solar system so we put that in a paper
and the paper was not published because
the referees argued well we don't know
the uncertainties in the government data
and obviously the government doesn't
want adversaries to be aware of the
sensors that it's using so it didn't
reveal the uncertainties and it took
them three years to end up confirming as
you said at the 99.99 confidence that
indeed the Aero budget is extremely
small which is what I expected because
they are responsible their day job is
National Security they have to figure
out if a ballistic missile is heading
towards Washington DC so they have very
precise data they put their reputation
on the line but I should say on the day
that we came back there was a paper
published in the astrophysical journal
by two astronomers who argued that they
are trying to fit the government data
with their model for Stony and iron
meteorites and they cannot do that and
therefore their conclusion was the data
must be wrong the speed that was
measured must be a factor of a few
smaller now the way I was brought up is
if your model doesn't fit the data then
you revise the model but instead what
they say quite arrogantly I should say
is the data must be wrong because our
models for solar system rocks do not fit
it well I said that long ago I said the
material strength of this object was
different than solar system rocks that's
why the models didn't fit it and just
think about the rotation curve of the
Milky Way galaxy you might argue oh the
rotation cap of the Milky Way galaxy
cannot be fit with assuming ordinary
matter that we find in the solar system
and therefore the data must be wrong
well no cosmology is all over the world
for by now it's 90 years are worried
about what this matter might be they
call it dark matter that's a main area
of research with billions of dollars
dedicated to finding what the dark
matter is but if we were to use the same
logic we would say we don't see this
matter in the solar system as of now and
therefore the data must be wrong and you
know that kind of logic perhaps is
adequate for traditional fields that
focused on space rocks but
intellectually that's not suitable for
exploring the universe beyond the system
the solar system because we know that 83
percent of the matter in the universe is
of a substance that we don't find in the
solar system and moreover we launched
probes out of the solar system so why
not allow for the possibility that this
object may be a voyager from an
exoplanet